I like getting stones my own like
nothing more than gets though
thanks for fiber with me man get stoned
waka flocka my first training ever was a
chain Gucci ball silver and green and
greenberg and green diamonds in house
place I got the chain it was over
probably cost about $8,500 75 now I
bought my cell phone
platinum Breitling put some green rubies
in it put a watch ring to match
everything to match it but just to see
when you get your first chain is like
yeah this one fog horn chain right here
it's a big old rooster you know we
firmly push the Pete because I so Pyro's
like you know that's a rule what I wrote
but I rooster so I felt like I was like
the biggest biggest rule when I was
writing that's when I wanted my first
talk by the way when i got this i was in
call paradise those me Dre meek mill's
French Montana and 2 Chainz
I'm I broke this chain I was in a crowd
if people was just stepping all on it
like bad but it in break kind of like
bent the foot knock some diamonds up
that was like during that years ago I
got fall going all white gold I want
this thing is just peaceful all my other
pieces because I want them to stand up
you know I'm saying it was big as hell
so if it's you know everything's like
I'm here
I paid by 80,000 he gave me a deal he
wouldn't like 120 I was just looking at
these changes here music as loud as [ __ ]
right now - I'm a wild wild west gun I
just bought this it's all gold white
Vivi's white canary diamonds this is
heavy as [ __ ] it's extremely heavy
this is solid Oh April I [ __ ] throw
this has somebody its top a villain not
to promote a bottle I love guns not the
things that the trigger could do when
you squeeze it I just love the science
behind it like as fires it's dope was
everything especially where I'm coming
from I have a father so my gums like my
father it was like a bully stop for like
it was comforting man you grow up on the
bottom man you gotta have something to
protect you like around pride 24 826
eight like this is non-stop my first
hang on was this fall for magma you see
that I stopped bullets in answer all
right
yeah stay loaded now anything shoot
watch this nice but every time I go to
the airport I put this chain on got put
in my carry-on don't wanna [ __ ] 25k it's
like $15,000 worth and gold bricks want
monopoly mint I love this January this
cherry of course in a 70k sol ego v vs d
color this right here cost me 5700 just
the gold chain itself his label was
everything man when I say bricks wat
monopoly it's a squat we're building our
label brick by brick and we monopolizing
rap that's it when you like yo that's
PSMs brick wall monopoly Oh shake of
Freddy Jarvan like literally man when
you have BSM I want you to think of
confetti drop because that's [ __ ]
brick SWAT monopoly confetti job
[Music]
let's ring so Brick Squad monopoly ring
this championship ring it's my Hall of
Famer and second ladies ring to me every
time I do a show like last two years
people like yell do what the [ __ ] you a
legend like act like it [ __ ] you a
legend Hill Brooklyn so that's why I'm
like you know something give my all the
fame ring on do my Michael Jordan [ __ ]
Kobe Bryant moves man Miz ringing solid
golden VVS tones its engraved with birds
around it to my wedding ring it's my
favorite ring right my wife bought this
ring for me I hate rings bro I hate like
where the rings is [ __ ] because just do
the history of it for the last decade
people that buy a ring for the marriage
it never works
it seems like you just don't want to
work so I feel like the Rings like a
[ __ ] Madden curse I just didn't like
that like I don't want to volume I love
on a rock I want to fight you love when
real love like real stability like real
real [ __ ] and my wife was like I
understand all that real [ __ ] but this
is ringing I want my ring I bought like
fall rings I lost all four of them is
each like 7500 a piece I lost all of
them like later I washed my hands and I
forgot to have your eggs up walk out of
the bathroom like five minutes later I'm
rushing
hello rings I'm in Memphis I'm like
[ __ ] they gone that's when I figured
I need start getting insurance on my
jury
guys think it was lame I ain't get no
insurance like everybody touching me uh
I made probably three hundred thousand
on it
[Applause]
young master - I bought these like four
years ago I haven't bought another watch
since this cost me $120 I got this week
before it came out and I busted all the
way down I'm going all the way and I
haven't found a watch better than this
watch riot period like a yacht - I
talking like a piece on protects and all
the skeletor's and they just don't feel
right like I'm just such a big
[ __ ] guy like this the only
watched I feel normal
[Music]
I love them I just love like [ __ ] I have
a roommate of [ __ ] diamonds I do my
next piece of jury will be I'm the white
gold yacht-master - or white gold fuzzy
some bracelets my three rings that's
gonna be like the new jury said if I had
the estimate was my entire collection I
could tell you right now for change my
watch
two watches a bracelet and four inks for
95 and that's a quarter of ain't gonna
be and I had my white [ __ ] some chain
other rings my green bracelet white
alright and I probably spent like two
2.5 million dollars a jerk if you ask me
now pushing everything I was out to get
all that [ __ ] what do you like
what was that thinking it was worth it
though
[Music]